- Imagine an implant on this butt.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
(high-spirited music)
- [Female Voice] What's so
attractive about the butt?
- [Male Voice] Sell it to me.
- You've got the cusp, the
roundness, you got the plumpness.
- (laughs) It jiggles.
- There's a lot you can do
with the booty. (laughing)
- Butts replicate your favorite fruit.
Peaches.
Plums.
Pears.
- Two grapes.
- Grapes are good.
- Kinda like a sweet apple,
You know, you just wanna
- Right.
- look at it and just, bite right into it.
- You never know what fruit you're
going to get out of the salad.
So it's kinda cool.
- I have never felt a butt implant before.
- Neither have I, honestly.
I don't know what to expect.
- I'm just afraid that it's gonna feel
so much like the real
thing, I won't be able
to tell what's real and
what's fake anymore.
- I want them to be
like, the boob implants.
Where they're just like, blubbbbb.
- (claps) This is so exciting,
we're going to touch butts.
(bright music)
- [Dr. Steve] Currently when
we discuss buttock implants
there is really one type of implant,
and that is a silicone buttock implant.
The outer shell is made of silicone, and
the inner part is a
thicker type of silicone
which is similar to a breast implant.
These implants are not
just strictly for women.
Obviously, there are men out there who are
going to the gym who are looking for
more volume for a firm buttocks.
The stigma of having plastic surgery
is certainly not longer what it use to be.
(lively music)
- Oh.
- Ooh, woe.
- [Both] Ohhh.
- It's hard as hell.
- It's more like a teardrop.
I mean. (laughing)
- That's not really a pillow butt,
I don't think so.
- Yeah.
- Let's see.
Ooooh.
I would actually like to wear
these, on the, (laughing)
cause it's like I don't have
that uncomfortable sensation.
It's like I'm always sitting in a sofa.
- I didn't know it was going to add
so much height.
- Right, it adds it.
- This is what I look like
sitting down regular, right.
This is what I look like,
- Yeah.
- (laughs) with a butt implant.
- Yo, I just grew crazy.
I'm gonna have to get some butt implants
just for height purposes.
(bright music)
- Oh, she's curvy.
- This is way
better, for my
- Ooh, yeah.
This passes the grape test.
- Aesthetic.
- Yeah, this is what I was imagining.
- Looks like the top of the earth.
- It's kinda cool, I like it.
I kinda fits right in your
palm, it's like you know,
you know like all those
basketball commercials. (laughing)
When it's like Michael Jordan
just gripping the ball.
- That's skin wrinkle.
- Feel pretty small, like. (laughing)
Right?
- I mean I guess like
butts aren't that big. (laughing)
- (smacking) Wow.
- I know feel (smacking)
- I like that one.
- It sounds like a real butt.
- Yeah that one's nice. (smacking)
- But I like the way
that this one feels more.
- Yeah, so I guess like if you like looks
over the feel, maybe this one.
- Yeah.
(bright music)
- Close your eyes.
- All righty.
- Here hold out your hands.
What do you think? (laughing)
- It feels like really gross skin.
- This looks like very chiseled.
Uh huh.
- Very chiseled implant.
- Is this for, like you
want that saggy effect.
- It also feels like one of
those mouse pads. (laughing)
- I was just going to say
Yeah. (laughing)
(smacking)
(laughing)
- [Male Voice] It does
not pass the slap test.
(laughing) That's a weak
cheek right there. (laughing)
- [Male Voice] This was like
a, learning experience for me.
- I didn't know there were so many
different kinds of butt implants.
- I was surprised at how much it
didn't look like my
image of butt implants.
- Yeah, no it was.
- It's not what I expected at all.
- If there is one thought in your mind
about getting a butt implant,
you make sure you do your homework.
- Right.
- You make sure you sample everything out.
You talk to people with
butt implants.
- Uh huh.
- You feel their butts,
you get completely ready.
- Do what makes you happy.
Put more fat in your butt or
don't put more fat in your butt.
Or do more squats or don't do more squats.
Do you boo, boo.
Do,
you.
- All butts are beautiful.
- (laughing) Butts are an
amazing gift to this planet.
(powerful music)